Brad Rushing, Cinematographer: Camera movement
does not automatically make a shot
better, it can make a shot worse.
Film Courage: How do you
decide when to move the camera?
Brad: Well again I primarily defer to
the director but I'm not one of those
people who likes gratuitous movement.
I've worked on shows there are certain
styles of filmmaking or gratuitous movement and
she's like always keep the camera moving I like it
to be motivated I like there to be a reason for it
to be moving and and I just intuitively it's like
when I'm in that space I’ll feel that moment where
I'm like we really should go from here and then
slide over to that person or just how cool we got
to follow them in through this door and outside
I would probably like to move the camera a little
more than I do but when you move the camera it can
complicate lighting because you have to hide
stands you're seeing more of the space you have
to have a and I if I was given a choice between
moving a camera or doing cool lighting I would I
would probably do the cool lighting I know people
who do less than cool lighting to permit more
camera movement and that again that's a legitimate
aesthetic but it's not my preferred aesthetic
but but in a perfect world you could have both
and again like I said I just unmotivated movement
it's a distraction I just I think even with
lighting I mean you could do cool lighting that
doesn't complement a scene and and it should never
be about making yourself look good it should be
about complimenting the actors and complimenting
the story telling telling that story in a way
that the the people lose themselves and it one of
the things that visual effects artists often say
is that is that our best work
is the work that nobody notices
and I feel that that's that's kind of true
for me I mean I always like it of course
when people say well that was really pretty
and beautiful but I hope that it's because
it complemented that moment and that they
they saw these two people in love and it
was just so beautiful and not that it was like
distracting in some kind of way because that's not
that's that doesn't serve the the the higher
purpose that we're all supposed to be there for
when you shot the video store one location
yeah teens sort of sounds like the thriller
yeah type movie what were you focusing on movement
or lighting or how are you making it interesting
within that one space well there was there was a
little bit of all of the above the director Rolf
Kanepski is just really passionate about coverage
he has lots of different ideas about about getting
a variety of coverage on scenes and again
we had motion where we needed to have it
and some of the things that we
did to keep that movie interesting
in the beginning of the movie they're
all standing up and they're talking and
so we kept like the top half of the walls had
colored bands on them and they had colored neons
and the bottom halfs of the walls were gray and so
we came up with a design where the lighting would
evolve and in the beginning it's just a very
neutral fluorescent lit thing with these these
neon signs and then this this conflict occurs
and at first people it's like all fun and games
and so they turn off the fluorescent lights and
I'm motivated from those neons I put my own lights
above them and I match those colors and it's like
now it's kind of a nightclub so I'm like they're
they're having fun it's kind of a nightclub
feel and then then things get more serious
and and those lights go out and there was a
there was there was a dramatic motivation for
that to happen and then there's a confrontation
where these spotlights are shining through the
windows and it became almost monochrome and and
the angles there were a lot of angles like this
so you're not seeing the colored bends anymore
you're seeing the gray you're seeing the ceiling
so all of those things it was like I remember
thinking man if it looks the same for 90 minutes
it's going to be so boring and and it's not
going to be dramatic and so the the lighting
had to be a partner with that story and and and
create those those moods and to Ralph's credit he
created that justification in
the story and with the characters
and and we had just a hell of a lot of fun
with it it was one of the things I love about
both that movie and California
Christmas is the variety of looks
I do like I love the look of of cook county
but it's mostly this kind of grim raw
look which is a cool look but like in California
Christmas you've got the breakfast scene and
you've got the barn at night where they're lifting
the food and you've got the party with the red
and you've got the bar with the blue and you've
got outside the bar usually you've got all these
different looks and that's just man that's so much
fun and and and those are the ones I'm proud of
and and so it was the same thing with this movie
tomorrow by midnight as you just have all these
really different looks and and then also as a
for an audience member it disconnects them from
what came before because it's like okay this
is visually this is a whole new thing we've
gone to another place and and that was
important for the story and it was important
to keep the visuals fresh again so people aren't
just going oh my gosh it's that wall again
how does camera movement make a shot better
the first thing that I would say is that is
that camera movement does not automatically
make a shot better it can make a shot worse
that would be like saying how does
drinking a margarita make things better
sometimes it does and there are other times
that well it probably wouldn't be the best thing
so in in terms of the ways in which it
does make it better is for instance if
we if we're slowly moving into somebody as
they're having a realization and that that
dawning is happening on their their face and and
as they're having the realization we're pushing
in we're getting close we're getting intimate
we're getting uncomfortably close to them the
audiences you're like you're carrying them along
and you're like oh my gosh I'm right in their face
and that emotion is just huge that's awesome or
or if you're discovering something you're you're
in a steadicam and you're following them and it's
like what is it what and you see them and they're
looking and what do you say oh my gosh whatever
things like that where you were again you are the
audience's proxy and and and how is it interesting
to them is it interesting to them to just sit and
watch these people talk blah, blah, blah, blah or
or do we feel we want to take that audience and
let's get them in closer or let's do a move
where we suddenly don't see this person's face
and they're going to be thinking why don't
I see that person's face what what are
they saying what are they doing what are they
looking at I have this really f favorite story
from rosemary's baby and the cinematographer was
talking about there's a scene where ruth gordon
is on a phone sitting on a bed and
and the camera's at the end of a hall
and the director said okay set the camera up so he
he got ruth gordon on the bed and she's perfectly
framed within the door and he sets up the cameras
this great shot and the director comes and he says
no, no, no move the camera we'll move the camera
over and he says okay he moves the camera over
and the director says no move it over some more
and he moved it over so far that all you see is
Ruth Gordon's back you don't see her face and
this guy's like okay well that's really weird
so they finish the movie they go into the
theater the DP’s sitting there watching an
audience watch the movie that scene comes on
and the audience goes to see around the door
now that's not an example of a move but that
is an example of what where are you taking
the audience with your camera and and and
really that's the when you get them to that
point where they are like so engaged with this
two-dimensional projection of light that their
primal instincts kick in and against common sense
they lean to see around the corner again just like
the the idea of the steadicam where you're leading
them through this place it's like you you're
building anticipation what am I gonna see I'm with
that character what's gonna happen to them what's
gonna come out of over there or or that emotional
moment where you get right up into the face
so again to me to me that's really what
it's all about it's about it's about
with the audience like how are you pushing those
those primal buttons in such a way that even a
non-verbal proto-humid would respond to what have
you been the most terrified on set and what is the
scariest shot you've ever gotten well the most
terrified I ever was on set gosh years ago now
I worked on this MTV show called senseless acts
of video and the premise was that they took
scenes in music videos crazy scenes that were
achieved by VFX and replicated them as stunts
and had some good time shooting that that was a
fun shoot but there was this one particular scene
we had this guy named troy he was our stunt man
and he had what's called a wing suit and in base
jumping that's people who basically just jump off
of buildings and cliffs and crap with a parachute
so pretty scary stuff and and one of the things
in base jumping is this this wing suit where
like rocky the squirrel you spread your arms
and these little bits of material come out and
I mean it doesn't it doesn't keep you aloft but it
lets you kind of rather than going straight down
it lets you get a little bit of soaring before
you deploy your your your your your parachute
and we were shooting in the grand canyon where he
was gonna jump off and I have a fear of heights
and and part of my fear of heights is
because I'm kind of clumsy and and I just
I don't want to stumble over something and
go over the edge because I'd be that guy
I'd be the guy in the news that went over the edge
and I remember we were shooting in an area
that was that was native American territory
so it didn't have the fences and the railings I
mean it's literally just there's the edge there's
oblivion and and and some of the guys are like
oh my gosh let's go look over the edge oh that's
awesome 1800 feet down brad come look come look
like hell no I wouldn't get within six feet of
that edge I figured if I'm gonna fall I'm gonna
have something to land on so I didn't do it and
because of the nature of the stunt we had a lot
of cameras and this was these were like tv sports
cameras the ones with the really big lenses the
super long zooms we were shooting it on video
and and I think I had gosh six eight cameras
plus I had a bunch of cameras mounted on this
there was also a plane and I remember I got there
and I and I asked the crew I wanted to be fair I
said who's afraid of heights and nobody said
they were afraid of heights and I said fine
I'm going to be on the camera at the bottom of
the canyon and you guys are going to be on the
ones around the edge they cabled them in everybody
had like a cable tied off to a stake or something
and the cameras were just right there and I was
like oh my gosh but but I would take a helicopter
go down which was also interesting because in the
canyon because the air is going through the canyon
it's very turbulent so as you go down it's like
oh but even I was okay with that because as long
as there's something between me and eternity I'm
okay so I even though that was uncomfortable it
was much better than standing at the edge of the
canyon but later on after we rap some of those
guys were like I was just myself and I'm like
you said you weren't afraid of heights I was I
was being diplomatic because if they had I mean
I don't know what I would have done drawn straws
or something but but I wouldn't I would have
tried not to make anybody who was uncomfortable
do it but that was that was to me the scariest
moment on set in terms of the scariest shot
wow I don't I don't have one offhand but
I'm well I do I do have one actually yeah so
we had this was 2002 and there were no
digital cameras there were no go-pros
and I had an airy 3 which is big 35 millimeter
camera and we were mounting them onto bikes to
get these really hot shots and we had one mounted
on the left rear tire of a bike and and it was
mounted with this rigging called doggy cam which
at the time was new and it was these thin rails
as opposed to speed rail which is this big big
much more rigid stuff and the the stunt was that
the bike was supposed to drive right at this car
and at the last minute veer off just a near miss
and so we rigged it now one of the things was
we had so many stunt riders on that that that
we had exhausted at least as I was told we had
exhausted the experienced people and they had
brought in trick riders people from Vegas who do
hot rod stuff that's not necessarily precision
movie stunts and I don't know if this person was
one of those I really don't but we did have some
people who were taking chances that the director
of the second unit director who was a professional
writer he was like don't do that that's that's
not what you're supposed to do but these guys
were hot doggers but anyone this particular
one I remember I was sitting standing on the
road and I see in the distance this car coming
and I see him just getting smaller and smaller
and then all of a sudden there was like this
explosion of black particles and he veered
and I realized what happened is he got so close
that the camera impacted the front of the car
blew into a billion pieces and I'm like my
gosh if that hadn't been doggy cam if that
had been speed rail it would have twisted him
up under the car and he would have been dead
and I'm just like son of a and the the line
producer who thank gosh is still a good friend
today but he was so mad understandably that
that camera was destroyed and he's like brad
you destroyed a camera and I'm like mike I it was
rigged where it was supposed to be it was rigged
appropriately and that dude just did not time
his move he did not gauge his distance and I
just I hate making excuses but I'm like I had no
control at that point and thank gosh it was rigged
safely so that it fell apart instead of taking
him under the car so yeah that was probably one
of the scariest because in that moment I was like
my gosh what happened and is that dude gonna die
how long did it take you to get over to where
that you saw him get smaller and smaller
I don't even remember I don't even know if I
went over there I probably did but it's like
that's the only part of it I remember is like
son of a and I and I just remember that thing
blowing into all those I just I wouldn't have
thought a camera could do that it just shattered.